volontaire pour être professeur
principaux ils sont aujourd'hui
démissionnaire
la faute à la réforme du bac dont ils ne
savent que peu de choses sur le papier
ils doivent aider les élèves de
terminale à choisir dans quelques
semaines quatre spécialités pour leur
orientation future
on n'a pas encore les programmes de la
classe de terminale comment les aider à
choisir leur spécialité sans connaître
les difficultés qu'ils pourront
rencontrer dans ses spécialités
par ailleurs on n'a pas les attendus du
post bac ça est assez complexe et je ne
me sentais plus la force
d'être prof principal dans ces
conditions conséquence directe de ces
démissions l'annulation du bac blanc
prévue début mars qui laisse ces
lycéennes perplexe parce que ça aurait
pu entraîner un petit peu avant le bac
mais du coup la communance prix mais je
pense que c'est plutôt un inconvénient
qu'un avantage poussé à faire ça pour
une meilleure forme après la presse ça
nous pénalise nous
vous pas de bac blanc à pergaud ni au
lycée ledoux ou victor hugo la réforme
passe mal fin janvier déjà les
enseignants avaient exprimé leur colère
devant le rectorat à besançon la
suppression des filières au profit de
spécialités inégalement réparties sur le
territoire est pour eux un nivellement
par le bas
partout on voit qu on appauvrit l'offre
éducative et ont vite de leurs contenus
tout un tas d'enseignement aucun des
enseignants ici ne souhaite démissionner
de ses fonctions en réalité notre vrai
problème c'est de protester refusé de
continuer d'accepter une dégradation des
conditions de travail qui va avoir lieu
avec cette réforme
en boycottant le bac blanc les
enseignants espèrent se faire entendre
ils se disent prêts à multiplier les
actions afin que le ministère revoit sa
copie et propose une nouvelle version de
sa réforme